elle nous entends monica bellucci nous
revenons en direct avec vous un
personnage vous ils vous m'entendez la
wii très bien il ya un personnage dans
le film qui vous demandent est ce que
montréal vous plaît alors je vous pose
la même question vous êtes venu tourner
il ya un an
est ce que montréal vous plaît écoutez
moi je peux dire que j'ai adoré braille
à montréal
c'est que
beaucoup aimé ces l'humaniste des gens
quelque chose que je les trouvais dans
la rue avec les gens que j'ai rencontrés
cette même année
je les retrouvais sur les plateaux et
guide doit c'est quelqu'un qui a une
autorité naturelle même temps un respect
pour l'équipe respect pour les acteurs
et je crois que je l'aï la possibilité
rapaille qui m'a plu aussi parce que
juste et soutenu
bailly et j'étais soutenu aussi pour
mais l'équipe
ces castes merveilleux d'acteurs québec
toi et je trouve que
c'est nous
les québec aujourd'hui
la présente beaucoup dans le monde
les acteurs de talent etc
quoique
même en europe qu'on regarde avec
beaucoup d'intérêt
et c'est que c'est beau c'est que
ceci est un point très intéressant entre
le rock
et les états unis
smx depuis
lang des cuisines je crois qu'il fait
vraiment la richesse de notre pays
j'y ai droit et vous a convaincu parce
qu'il est moins connue du doigt c'est un
jeune réalisateur
comment il vous a convaincu d'embarquer
dans ce projet
et j'avais lu le scénario et j'ai dû
oui tout de suite au scénario avant
d'avoir vu marécages
et j'ai mon mariage et j'ai adoré
pascale bussières fait un travail
vraiment amer
c'était très mode et travaille avec elle
dans session
les gens verront c'est un film complexe
et un film fort intéressant où vous
votre rôle et j'aimerais vous entendre
là tout vous avez dit c'est la première
fois que vraiment je me suis laissé
aller les gens me voient dans ce qu'il
ya de plus vulnérables chez moi
maintenant
c'est un rôle qui m'a permis de jouer
sur plusieurs facettes
et comme j'ai déjà dit c'est un reliquat
d'open comédienne parce que
c'est comme si ma donné plusieurs notes
sur lesquels
on va jouer un peu comme si j'étais avec
un piano et comme je dis toujours les
comédiens
comme les danseurs on ferait avec les
corps
et
quelquefois les mots sont pas suffisants
pour eric et les émotions
alors qu'elle est encore et toujours la
raison
pour moi
explications
il est montré
et voilà et pour ce rôle c'était le cas
prix
quand j'invite les gens à les voir sur
film c'est vraiment intéressant et un
coulissage entre deux niveaux parce que
vous êtes une comédienne dans le film
tourné un film il ya votre fils qui
habite ici à montréal il ya une
direction photo aussi qui est magnifique
on voit des bouts de montréal comme on
les a pas vus mais avant de vous laisser
aller dites-moi est-ce que james bond
est tombé amoureux de vous écouter
pour moi la garde de chance
c'est de pouvoir tourner avec des
personnes différentes qui ont
des univers différents et du coup des
tournées avec bédouins
mendes on y repense au ritz avec qui je
suis en train de tourner à ce moment
voilà c'est ça la vraie richesse pour
une comédienne
tu chef d
art différent
cultures différentes
ça devient une expérience et pas
seulement contre médias
mais aussi comme
autrement tout simplement il avait dit
ce matin vous êtes une bande lady et non
pas une bande girl
oui parce que jugée trop mûr pour être
considéré
d'accord mais je crois que c'est
c'était une belle choix de la part de
sam mendes des pandas et fameux mur
je vais
un rôle de james bond c'est une grande
première c'est vrai les gars
non c'est une
voilà un descabello tue au nom de toute
l'équipe des gens qui nous écoutent je
vous souhaite un joyeux anniversaire
c'est votre anniversaire aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup c'est très gentil tous
mes roues chinois les bons cadeaux c'est
d'être ici
ville merveilleuse avec
gens qui m'entourent
chaleureuse et voilà et là je vais voir
les films pour la première fois nous
avons bonne soirée première bon séjour à
montréal à bientôt et merci
on sera tous